[Musique]
si vous croyez en ce que vous faites
et pourquoi vous le faites le champ du
possible s'ouvre devant vous après dix
ans de mariage
trois jeux les enfants une maison à vie
normale boulot mi temps tout se passe
bien
arrive notre quatrième enfant
honorine au grand plaisir de ses frères
et soeurs après quelques mois je
m'aperçois corinne se développent moins
rapidement que ses aînés je m'interroge
elle sourit - après en moins j'en parle
à mon médecin lors d'une visite médicale
qui me répond comme tout bon médecin de
famille ne vous inquiétez pas c'est
normal c'est une petite dernière et
prend son temps à six mois la fontanelle
du craint de se faire
et là commence plusieurs interrogations
pour se poser la question pourquoi cette
fontanel qui énorme annonce ferme autour
de 18 mois est clôturée en discutant
avec divers spécialistes il décide de
l'hospitaliser honorine pour trois jours
afin de comprendre pourquoi cette
fontanel c'est vers mais cela va durer
dix jours les diplômes jour de ma vie
après une hospitalisation éprouvante
notre petit bébé de six mois a failli
perdre la vie
nous apprenons la nouvelle honorine est
atteinte d'une maladie génétique appelée
licence et fanny c'est une malformation
du cortex cérébral
on nous explique que la soirée
handicapés à vie quel son développement
sera très limitée et qu'elle soit
épileptiques
[Musique]
heureusement nous étions de quatre
oreilles pour entendre ça car nous
n'avons pas du tout entendu les mêmes
choses par contre nous avons bien retenu
une chose quand la neurologue nous dit
la vie d'hier ne sera jamais plus la vie
de demain nous sortons l'hôpital avec
plus de questions que de réponses
mais tout s'enchaîne très vite il faut
donner des nouvelles à la famille et
surtout expliquer à nos aînés
l'inexplicable
nous ne sommes pas prêts à ça mais vous
êtes parents avant tout et vous vous
devez de relever ce défi qui vous paraît
insurmontable
nous découvrons également la jungle du
handicap
entre les prises en charge
l'administratif mais différents rendez
vous chez les spécialistes
un vrai boulot à plein temps je dois
renoncer à reprendre mon activité
professionnelle pour m'occuper
d'honorine et de mes deux autres enfants
nous découvrons également co noreen
souffre de trois handicaps à la fois
c'est ce qu'on appelle le polyhandicap
mot totalement inconnu pour moi
auparavant
nous découvrons aussi que le parcours
proposé est de une à deux heures par
semaine seulement
or on nous explique que la prise en
charge des enfants aussi lourdement
handicapé le plus précocement possible
permet d'avoir un certain développement
mais aucune structure ne peut
l'accueillir avant l'âge de 6 ans alors
nous devons faire quelque chose pour
notre enfant comme nous voulons pour
tous nos autres enfants offrir le
meilleur de ce que nous pouvons après
quelques semaines nous décidons de nous
relever à 2 de rebondir et de nous
battre pour notre fille et je découvre
alors en moins des ressources
insoupçonnées
nous décidons de créer une association
afin de pouvoir commencer à faire des
simulations sur honorine cette
association nous allons l'appeler
honorine lève toi
lors de notre première assemblée
générale constitutive
nous sommes devant 80 personnes et nous
sommes très surpris
80 personnes qui viennent gratuitement
bénévolement au 21ème siècle
incroyable mais c'est par cet élan de
générosité nous décidons d'aller de
l'avant
je m'informe je forme des bénévoles et
nous commençons les premières
simulations sur honorine on ne rit
n'avait pas un nom à trois ans honorine
a beaucoup progressé
c'est in estimé pour les médecins qui la
suivent alors nous devons aller plus
loin pour continuer à lui offrir quelque
chose de meilleur encore
toujours sur internet nous découvrons la
méthode d'éducation conductivité est une
méthode de rééducation qui permet aux
enfants d'apprendre les gestes de la vie
quotidienne et de les emmener vers les
chemins de l'autonomie léger de la vie
quotidienne comme apprendre à manger
apprendre à se déplacer apprendre à
prendre un objet dans la main ou est
propre
des choses très simples qui vous
paraissent pour vous et moi mais qui
pour eux eux sont des mouvements très
complexe
la philosophie de cette méthode repose
sur la conviction que chaque enfant a
une capacité d'apprentissage est elle
mise sur la plasticité cérébrale afin de
créer de nouvelles connexions pour
toutes celles qui seraient endommagés
mal formés ou absente
nous découvrons que le seul sentent
qu'ils existent et dans le sens de la
france alors eh bien allons-y
je prends honorine et bras dessus bras
dessous nous partons pour découvrir si
cette méthode d'éducation objectif
correspond au handicap de notre fille et
qui puisse leur permettre de progresser
après six semaines
je rentre et là mon époux me dit mais ce
n'est plus la même
elle a énormément progressé nous avons
trouvé ce qu'il faut pour en or in l'un
se pose
deux possibilités ou bien nous
déménageons tout le monde dans le centre
de la france mais ma foi le soleil
normand nous on le pas mal ou bien nous
décidons de créer une école au mongol
homologue ici en normandie
après une étude de faisabilité nous ne
rendons compte que beaucoup de parents
et d'enfants sont dans la même situation
que nous
alors nous décidons de nous lancer dans
cette aventure un peu folle et
périlleuse
ça ne doit pas être facile mais c'est
pas parce que c'est pas facile que nous
n'allons pas essayer n'offrant plus tard
l'école ouvre ses portes et durant cette
année nous avons dû trouver cent
cinquante mille euros de dons pour faire
fonctionner cette école nous avons dû
trouver des professionnels qui veulent
bien nous suivre dans cette aventure et
des parents qui sont un peu fou comme
nous pour nous suivre dans cette
aventure mais cela s'avérait une belle
réussite
pourquoi une réussite parce que les
médecins qui suivent tous les enfants du
centre sont les premiers convaincus ou
bien fait d'éducation conductivité à une
réussite parce que après sept ans de
longues discussions avec administration
nous avons obtenu une reconnaissance par
un financement public
mais pourquoi et surtout parce que
chaque enfant ont progressé
certes ils ont tous progressé à leur
vitesse honorine par exemple cela lui a
pris cinq ans apprendre à manger
ça fait quatre ans que nous sommes sur
l'apprentissage de la propreté
probablement que ça va lui prendre un
petit peu plus de temps mais l'essentiel
c'est quoi c'est qu'elle est heureuse et
épanouie et puis entre vous et moi est
ce qu'on lui demandera un jour à quel
âge as-tu marché non nous avons marché
avec honorine sur de long chemin
périlleux
nous avons gravi des montagnes franchi
des sommets mais le chemin est encore
long
aujourd'hui honorine à 11 ans elle se
tient debout presque toute seule elle
mange quasiment tout seul
elle dit une centaine de mots comprend
beaucoup de choses aime beaucoup
l'interaction avec les autres est
heureuse alors en effet la vie d'hier ne
sera jamais plus la vie de demain mais
notre plus belle récompense c'est le
sourire et l'épanouissement d'honorine
au milieu de ses frères et soeurs nous
n'oublierons jamais toutes les personnes
empli d'humanité et de générosité que
nous avons pu rencontrer
mais au-delà de cette expérience qui a
permis d'ouvrir six autres centres
d'autant en france et qui a permis
surtout d'accueillir et de donner cette
possibilité à d'autres enfants
c'est surtout le sentiment d'avoir
initié un nouvel espoir à tous ces
parents qu'ils puissent s'émerveiller
devant chaque progrès de l'enfant devant
chaque petit geste qui donne un sens et
du plaisir à la vie alors
si vous croyez en ce que vous faites et
pourquoi vous ne faites rien est
impossible
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]